[Musica]
questa serie 3 di alzarmi in piedi si
alzatevi tutti in piedi per cortesia e
vi chiederei di pensare a un numero a
caso il primo che mi viene in mente fra
1 e chiedo di lasciare un po di luce in
sala per cortesia in modo da poterli
appunto vedere tutte vi chiedo di
pensare proprio questo numero a caso tra
1 e 10 mi avete in mente io vi chiedo
proprio di visualizzarlo di fronte a voi
proprio come qualcosa di concreto
ne avete in mente uno in questo momento
sì molto bene e quindi una platea di
persone che sta visualizzando qualcosa
che non esiste questo è fantastico
chiedo se possibile di alzare ancora un
po alle luci in sala in modo da vedervi
un po meglio vicino di essere sinceri se
state pensando al numero 7 vi chiedo di
accomodarvi
questo perché lo vedete anche voi numero
7 generalmente il numero più scelto in
questa tipologia di esperimenti io non
vorrei che al termine appunto di questo
esperimento voi pensiate che ciò a cui
abbiamo assistito abbia a che fare in
qualche modo con la statistica
no non c'entra nulla la statistica non
c'entra proprio nulla se siete in pieno
in questo momento sta ripensando al
numero fare 110 può essere qualsiasi
numero a parte il 7 è solo voi conoscete
questo non hanno i servirà un numero
solo
e per questo andrò ora scegliere una
persona
fra tutti voi a caso
andrea ad esempio sulla signora in
seconda fila
chiedere a tutti noi altri di
accomodarvi mentre io faccio consegnare
alla signora quei questa busta
chi è qui accanto ma è appunto questa
busta chiusa e sigillata
molto bene le chiedo di accomodarsi qui
accanto a me e
richiedo intanto il suo nome
mara mara è una domanda mara ha scelto
lei di chiamarsi mara
mi chiedo no no è chiaro no
e dov'è nata nei periodi di romanzi ero
nata a massa marittima
e anche qui ha scelto lei di nasce nella
massa marittima no è quello che
risponderemo a tutti naturalmente però
ora lei sta pensando come tutti un
numero
quest'ora scelto lei sì
ma mi è proprio sicura penso di sì
può dirci per la prima volta perché fino
a questo momento questo non è solo nella
sua mente per la prima volta può dirci
qual è il numero che sta pensando
il numero 3
gli ho consigliato questa busta o
aprirla per favore
mi chiedo di estrarre il contenuto
di leggere con voce forte e chiara tutto
ciò che c'è scritto su questo foglio
allora sapevo avresti scelto il numero 3
christa ris christopher castellini
sapevo avresti scelto il numero 3 il
numero 3
grazie io al recupero il microfono che
in questo momento non serve più il
foglio può assolutamente tenerla un
piccolo ricordo per lei
quando ho cominciato ad avere il
desiderio di fare esperimenti come
questo c'era qualcuno chi mi diceva che
non avrei mai fatta e questo qualcuno mi
diceva che se mai ce l'avessi fatta a
nessuno sarebbe mai venuto a vedere i
miei spettacoli
io sono felice di aver smentito questo
qualcuno ho trovato il modo di fare
questi esperimenti avuto la fantastica
possibilità di lavorare anni in teatri
straordinari veramente splendidi
meravigliosi che un avrei mai potuto
immaginare in tutto il mondo è stato
realizzato il primo italiano a
conquistare il podio al campionato del
mondo di mentalismo e appunto sono
felice di aver potuto smentire questo
qualcuno che mi diceva che non si avrei
mai fatto e sapete la cosa più
interessante quale e che questo qualcuno
ero io
io non conosco il tuo nome non so dove
sei nato
ma so che certamente ci sono volte in
cui sei tu che qualcuno che cerca di
buttare digiuno che ti dice che non sei
abbastanza che non sei all'altezza che
non potrai mai farcela io sono qui ad
aiuti che tu sei abbastanza
che tu sei all'altezza che tu ce la puoi
fare
e se credi il contrario è perché c'è
qualcosa di te stesso che ancora non
accetti io non accettavo molte cose di
me forse tu vorresti essere più alto più
bello più simpatico per intelligente i
media ci propongono ogni giorno modelli
di perfezione che in realtà non esistono
non può essere al loro livello perché
quel livello non è reale e di cartapesta
la vera perfezione non è essere tutti
uguali messere originali essere dei
modelli unici se stessi possiamo
viaggiare in tutto l'universo e non
troveremo mai un'altra persona che sia
uguale a te sei speciale e forse credi
che i tuoi sogni non possono realizzarsi
a causa di situazioni che tu non
vorresti avere nella vita ma l'unico
modo che hai per avvicinare i tuoi sogni
e quello di attraversare tutte queste
situazioni tutte queste zone d'ombra c'è
anche la possibilità che forse tu non
accetti qualcosa che non riguarda i
presenti forse poi tornare nel passato
e cambiare alcune tue scelte
e ho una brutta notizia in una bella
notizia la brutta che indietro non si
torna
ma la bella è che il presente è tuo
di nessun altro
in questo istante possono venire cose
sensazionali
se tu riesci a liberarvi dalla paura di
affrontare le tue zone d'ombra per le
tre zone d'ombra sono soltanto aspetti
della tua storia
che non sono ancora state illuminate
nella nostra vita ci possono essere
ostacoli apparentemente insormontabili
ma abbiamo sempre la possibilità di
scegliere di scegliere quale voce
ascoltare
la voce che ti invita a nascondere di a
fuggire
oppure la voce più profonda e autentica
più vera la voce che ti invita a vivere
il presente senza paura
che cos'è la forza
se non la capacità di battere una
resistenza
se non ci fossero ostacoli non avremo
nessun motivo per allenarci per prendere
la rincorsa per cercare di vincere una
gara che è anzitutto una gara con noi
stessi per cercare di migliorarci ogni
giorno e per cercare di realizzare si di
realizzare ciò che siamo veramente
quindi proviamo per un istante a
immaginare come sarebbe la nostra vita
se non avessimo più paura di affrontare
le nostre zone d'ombra
mi piacerebbe guidarli in questo piccolo
viaggio con la vostra immaginazione
con un piccolo e semplice esercizio che
vorrà invitare tutti voi veramente a
fare io video di piantare bene i piedi
per terra a restare dritti con la
schiena e vi chiedo
chiudere gli occhi
fiore dei vostri occhi vi chiedo di
ascoltare il vostro respiro i battiti
del vostro cuore
immaginate di sentirvi sempre più
carichi più freschi perché luminosi più
pieni di energia come quando eravate
bambini consapevoli che l'impossibile
davvero non esiste perché ogni cosa può
essere possibile nella vostra vita vi
chiedo di immaginare di aprire uno dei
vostri cassetti dove magari avete
abbandonato uno dei vostri soldi e non
parlo di sogni realizzabili ma qualcosa
di semplice di concreto che potete fare
nell'immediato nella vostra vita un
sogno veramente a portata di mano ma che
forse ancora non avete realizzato una
cosa che possa migliorare la vostra vita
e la vita delle persone che vi
circondano
vi sentite sempre più carichi di energia
e sicuri di voi stessi e veramente vi
chiede di scegliere un sogno qualcosa di
concreto di bello di positivo
visualizzare proprio questa immagine
nella vostra mente come qualcosa di
concreto e vi chiedo di cercare di
compensare questo sogno in alcune parole
nella vostra mente bastano forse anche
23 una frase al massimo e ora vi chiedo
ancora di fare un grande respiro e di
aprire i vostri occhi aprite i vostri
occhi
sono volta poltrone avete trovato oggi
una busta con una penna vi chiedo di
prendere questa piccola busta con questa
pena è un piccolo regalo per voi vi
chiedo di estrarre dalla busto di
cartoncino vuoto che appunto è contenuto
e vi chiedo per voi stessi di scrivere
su questo cartoncino questo sogno queste
parole che lo caratterizzano questa
breve frase proprio scrivetela per
cortesia su questo piccolo foglio come
un aiuto per voi sarà un foglio che
resterà appunto a voi e appunto fissati
ora questo sogno come se steste proprio
fissando un obiettivo
questo posto desiderio in qualche modo
possiamo chiamarlo che nasce dal vostro
cuore e lumina la vostra mente e quando
avete scritto questo sogno vi chiedo di
richiudere appunto la busta di tenerla a
portata di mano
e
forse qualcuno di voi oggi si chiede
come io abbia potuto fare in modo che si
realizzasse so che io avevo scritto
all'inizio molto prima di arrivare su
questo palcoscenico sulla busta che
avevo qui insieme a poco fa
io non sono qui a dire come io ho
realizzato ciò che era scritto la mia
busta
ma sono qui a dirvi che voi potete
realizzare quello che è scritto nella
vostra
e come
avendo fiducia in voi stessi nella vita
ricordandovi che non potete scegliere il
vostro passato
volete scegliere il vostro presente
potete scegliere quale voce ascoltare
potete scegliere sempre la voce più
potente più luminosa più incredibile che
dentro di voi riporta ad inseguire
sempre i vostri sogni vi ricorda che
potete farcela
ascoltate quella voce profonda rileggete
ogni giorno questo vostro sogno
inseguito lo con costanza con impegno
con fiducia e questo è il primo passo
per trasformare l'impossibile
impossibile vivere ogni giorno una vita
straordinaria
grazie
[Musica]